tomorrow we're wrapping up I know you
got one more story you a candy-themed
I'm a candy-themed man I love can you
can't keep can around me I need to hear
this story about when you were on a
plane I'm just gonna tease let's explain
what happens I'm with my guys and I see
a whole bunch of cannon boys eating the
candy and I like much we are coming from
Buffalo this is my this is my rookie
year coming from Buffalo so you know
that's six and a half hour flight so you
know everybody talked about you know hey
you got some brownies Ronnie you like
some brownies brownies all right cool
you know I don't think it's a muscle I
okay sobriety if it is what level man
I'm sorry
grab me cane I ain't know what it was
and I said you sure you want me so I'm
eating it so so we send out we eating
the brownies and I'm like okay crew what
the hell you're brown is I said [ __ ] I
hate my brownie you sound was a candy
but what really wasn't my first time it
was tasting the elder in my life and
like proto Friday got a weed in it like
what you know no brownie got no damn
lead in all thing I knew was
backward-ass wishes now coming from I'm
a Florida player going on a carrot or my
son--my some edible ain't never heard
nothing edible in my life I go in the
meat room and a coach is like a washing
foot still I thought that I should never
get it today so all of a sudden start
feeling started getting high I'm talking
to Lorenzo Lorenzo near that point in
time who's the full-back for us
hey hey little man are you not getting
my heartbeat it's like man I think I'm
about to die
it's late man crews not about the dollar
like nah brah bout the dog man I can't
do it bro
sounds like he said something there so
I'm done laughing can't stop I can't
stop stop laughing man I don't know
what's wrong with me but I never feel
like this is my life so they'll just
send down like man come on y'all help me
help me please please come over I got my
heart hurt my head hurt Kosovo Jamal you
outside your room you go downstairs to
see the trainer he'll meet everybody
laughing like what you watching was
opposed to really do or somebody that
down hi they don't know what the hell go
at all so I'm walking downstairs and I'm
crying and I'm crying so I'd actually
love and locker room laying on the
ground they said you didn't get no sleep
but nothing no I couldn't go to sleep I
was gonna die now maybe will you heal
when you close your eyes you can hear
your heart beating like this are you
going to sleep go to sleep it's too hot
on the plane even though one high yeah
exactly that's the whole thing when you
send are you high
and you start having hot flashes pad I'm
like man out on Mount you really took
off my shirt and rings do all that like
no it's all laid on the ground for come
in they gave me some some chocolate milk
it kind of calmed me down then I deny
okay
walking that column in and then it hit
me again I start crying in laughing say
it sound like Jamie Muro
we got trying to hide this from the
coaches what's up I don't know if it was
so much hot and they just brought him on
as brownie yeah you know cuz they I
thought it was real brownies but here
something else
[Music]